messieurs on est des pompiers
parachutistes la meilleure équipe de
pompiers d'élite au monde faut donner le
meilleur de nouvelles chaque seconde de
chaque jour
faites-moi décembre faites ce que je dis
est faite le matin il a dit maintenant
revers pour l'extraction quoi
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce qu'on vous rendent à vos
parents je suis légalement chargé de
prendre soin de vous en retour vous
allez mourir et on pourra faire notre
travail et faire c'est juste la gens
comme ça masai pas sous mes ordres pas
de magouilles mois gros pompiers m'ont
coupat tourneux ce qui va arriver en 7
secondes précise si tu vas à la boucle
et la grande soeur ou quoi broyeur va
venir te donner une leçon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le bébé à
briser votre chien sous quand je suis
distrait j'arrive pas faire mon travail
où est passé votre esprit d'enfant on
vous a tué
[Musique]
j'ai tourné des supers culinaire c'est
pas du joual
[Musique]
là c'est la fête
dans quinze jours de pompiers vous êtes
c'est dur à croire mais il est gentil
dauphin
aussi kenshin yann ça
boum c'est quoi pour vous non pour qu'un
pas ou n'ont arrêté où je vais